so from looking at your imdb page you've
appeared in roughly 87 projects or so is
it that many uh i believe so yeah well
we'll check with my intern back i know
i'm kidding that's us so no
um but do you still need to audition i
mean obviously
you've been called in for dumb and
number two but
that's still just a normal part of what
you do yeah auditioning is
that hasn't gone away yet
um
offers are being made a little bit more
often now
that i have a little bit of name
recognition and face recognition and and
people have worked with me um
a time or two
um
and that's what's so important about
relationships i i just can't stress
enough how
important it is to cultivate
relationships um
it's going to sound terrible
i know i'm not the only one though
i used to
use criteria for whether or not i would
want to work on a project just based on
the
um
on the importance of the project or its
visibility or
the the paycheck if the paycheck wasn't
enough then i wasn't interested
and you know those those days are over
those those times have changed it is
much more maybe it always was much more
about relationships and forming
relationships and the
the people that you're going to work
with today you will also be working with
tomorrow and the next day in the next
year and two three four five years down
the line as well and
it's important to cultivate those
relationships because it's like planting
a seed it sounds silly but that seed
will germinate and grow and turn into
other
wonderful things down the line nine
times out of ten well you said that you
didn't always think like that so can you
tell me a story when there was a turning
point i find that interesting no i can't
remember the exact turning point
well yeah there there was something that
hit me kind of hard at an audition there
was a very very well-known actor there
who was auditioning for a
he was a former series regular and he
was auditioning
for a guest star
on this show
same part that i was reading for
and i just asked him in the room
i am so surprised that you're even
sitting here with the rest of us and
auditioning for this role
and he said you know what
it doesn't matter anymore doesn't matter
anymore it's all about the relationships
and if i can form a new relationship
with
a person or a group of people by
coming into the audition room and
meeting them that way that's what i'm
going to do
and i thought
wow
i never thought of it that way i never
thought of it that way and and
it's true it's true also
delivery platforms have changed now and
things that i wouldn't have considered
doing
five six seven years ago like webisodes
webisodes ooh
um now yeah if you have a cool webisode
that is interesting and has an
interesting cast and crew attached i'm
there you bet because the delivery
platform is irrelevant now
it's the number of eyeballs and you can
get the number of the same number of
eyeballs on television that or on
on youtube
or on the internet
as you can get on television now